The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEREMY KEPNER: Welcome.
Happy Halloween.
And for those of you
watching this video at home,
you'll be glad to know the
whole audience has joined me
and they're all dressed
out in costumes.
And it's a real fun
day here as we do this.
So making me not feel
alone in my costume.
A lot of moral support
there, so that's great.
So, yeah.
So this is Lecture 05 five on
Signal Processing on Databases,
just for a recap.
For those of you who
missed earlier classes
or are going this out
of order on the web,
signal processing really
alludes detection theory,
finding things, which
alludes to the underlying
mathematical basis of that,
which is linear algebra.
And the databases
really refers to working
with unstructured data, strings,
and other types of things.
Two things that aren't
really talked about together,
but we're bringing
them together here
because we have lots of new
data sets that required it.
And so this talk is
probably the one that's
getting most into
something that we would say
relates to detection
theory, because we're
going to be dealing with a lot
with background data models.
And in particular,
power laws and methods
of constructing
power law data sets,
methods on sampling and fitting,
and using that as a basis
for doing the kind of
work that you want to do.
So moving in here.
So just your outline.
And so we've got a lot of
material to go over here today.
This is all using
the data set, when
we get into the data
set that we talked
about in the last lecture,
which is this Reuters data set.
So we'll be applying some of
these ideas to that data set.
So just going to--
introduction here,
and then I'm going
to get to sampling
theory, and subsampling theory,
various types of distributions.
And then end up with
the Reuter's data set.
The overall goal
of this lecture is
to really develop a background
model for these types of data
sets that is based on what I'm
calling a perfect power law.
And then we're
going to, basically,
after we can construct
a perfect power law,
we're going to
sample that power law
and look at what happens
when we sample it.
What are the effects
of sampling it?
And then we can
use the power law
to look at things like
deviations and such.
Now you might ask,
well, why are we
so concerned about
backgrounds and power laws?
And it's because here's sort
of the basis of detection
theory on one slide.
So in detection
theory, you basically
have a model which consists
of noise and the signal,
and you have two
hypotheses, H0, which
is there's only
noise in your data,
and H1 that there's
signal plus noise.
And so, essentially, when you
do detection theory, what you're
doing is given these
models, you can then
compute optimal filters
for answering the question,
is there a signal there
or is it just noise?
That's essentially what
detection theory boils down to.
In this data, now when we
deal with graph theory,
it's obviously not so clean in
terms of our dimensions here.
We'll have some kind of
high dimensional space
and our signal will
be projected into
that high dimensional space.
But nevertheless, the concept
is still just as important
that we have noise and a signal.
And that's what we're
trying to do here.
Detection theory works in
the traditional domains
that we've applied
it to because we
have a fairly good model for
the background, which tends
to be Gaussian random noise.
It's kind of the
fundamental distribution
that we use in lots
of our data sets.
And if we didn't
have that model,
it would be very difficult
for us to proceed
with much of detection theory.
And the Gaussian
random noise model
works, because in many
respects, if you're
collecting sensor
data, you really
will have Gaussian
physics going on.
You also-- law of
large numbers in terms
of if you have lots of
different distributions
that are pulled together,
they will end up
beginning to look like
a Gaussian as well.
So that's what we have in
many of the traditional fields
that we've worked in
in signal processing,
but now we're in this new
area where a lot of our data
sets arrive from artificial
processes, processes that
are a result of human actions.
Be it data on a network, be
it data in a social network,
be it other types of data
that have a strong sort
of artificial element to them.
We find that the
Gaussian model does not
reveal itself in the same way
that we've seen in other sets.
So we need this.
We really need a
background model,
so we have to do
something about it.
So there has been a fair amount
of research and literature
to come up with first
principles, methods
for creating power law
distribution in data sets.
We talked a little bit
about these distributions
in the previous lectures.
And they've met
with mixed results.
It's been difficult
to come up with,
what is the underlying
physics of the processes
that result in certain
vertices in graphs
having enormous number of
edges and other vertices
only having a few?
And so there has
been work on that.
I encourage you to look
at that literature.
Here we're going to do
much more of a-- sort of go
from the reverse
direction, which
is let's begin by coming up
with some way to construct
a perfect power law.
With no concept of well, what
is the underlying physics
motivating this?
Essentially, a basic linear
model for a perfect power law.
That we probably can do.
And then we'll go from there.
And linear models are
something that we often
use in our business.
And it's a good
first starting point.
So along those
lines, this is a way
to construct a perfect
power law in a matrix.
This is basically a
slide of definitions
here, so let me spend a little
time going through them.
So we're going to represent
our graph or our data
as a random matrix.
Basically of zero where there's
no connection between-- this
is a set of vertices connected
with another set of vertices.
There are N out of
these vertices and N
in of these vertices.
You have a dot here.
The row corresponds to the
vertex at the edge left,
and the column
corresponds to the vertex
that the edge is going into.
So this adjacency
matrix A is just
going to be constructed
by randomly filling
this matrix with entries.
And the only real constraint
on them is that when you sum A,
we're going to allow
multiple edges.
So you can have more--
the values aren't just
zero and one, but they
can have more than that.
But when you sum the matrix
A, all its values up,
you get a value M, which is
the total number of edges
in the graph.
So we have essentially a
graph with-- this could
be a bipartite graph or not.
But with essentially N out
vertices, N in vertices, and M
total edges.
The perfect power
law, we're going
to have essentially two
perfect power laws here.
One on the out degree.
So if you sum these rows,
and then you do a histogram,
you're going to want to
produce a histogram that
looks something like this.
So you have an out
degree for each vertex.
And this would show how many
vertices have that out degree.
And so our power law
says that these points
should fall on a slope
with a negative power law
coefficient of alpha out.
So that's essentially
the one definition there.
And then when you likewise
have another going
in the-- for the other degree.
So the in degrees have
their own power law.
So these are the definitions.
This is what we're saying
is a perfect power law.
So we're saying a perfect
power law has these properties.
Now we're going to
attempt to construct it.
We have no physical
basis for saying why
the data should look this way.
We're just saying this is
a linear model of the data
and we're going to
construct it that way.
And again, these can be
undirected, multi-edge,
we can allow self-loops
and disconnected vertices,
and hyper-edges.
Anything you can get by
just randomly throwing down
values onto a matrix.
And again, the
only constraint is
that the sum in
both directions is
equal to the number of edges.
So given that, can we
construct such a thing?
Well, it turns out we can
construct such a thing fairly
simply.
And so in MATLAB we can
construct a perfect power law
graph with this four
line function here.
It will construct a
degree distribution
that has this property.
And the three number
parameters to this distribution
are alpha, which
is the slope, dmax,
which is the maximum
degree vertex,
and then this number
Nd, which is roughly
proportional to
the number of bins
that we're going to have here.
Essentially the
number of points.
It's not exactly that, but
roughly proportional to that.
And so when you do this
little equation here,
the first thing
that you will see
is we are going to be creating
a logarithmic spacing of bins.
We kind of need to do that here.
But at a certain point,
we get below a value
where the spacing will be--
we'll have essentially one
bin per integer.
And so these are two
very separate regimes.
You're going to have one
which is called the integer
regime, where basically
each integer has
one-- is representative.
And then it transitions
to a logarithmic regime.
You might say this is
somewhat artificial.
It's actually very reflective
of what's really going on.
We really see here--
we really have a dmax,
we really have, almost
always, a count at 1.
And then we have
a count at 2 or 3,
and then they start
spreading out.
And so this is just
an artificial way
to create this type
of distribution,
which is a perfect
power law distribution.
So it's a very simple,
very efficient code
for creating one of these.
It has a smooth transition
from what we call the integer
bins and the logarithmic bins.
And it also gives a very nice
what we call poor man slope
estimator.
So there's a lot of
research out there
about how do you estimate
the slope of your power law.
And there's all kinds of
algorithms for doing this.
Well, the simplest way is just
to take the two endpoints.
Take the first point
and the last point,
and you know you're
perfectly fitting two points.
And you could argue
you're perfectly fitting
the two most important points.
And you get this nice, simple
value for the slope here.
In addition, you can
make the argument
that regardless of
how you bin the data,
you'll always have
these two bins.
You will always
have a bin at dmax
and you will always
have a bin at 1.
And all the other bins
are going to be somewhat
a matter of choice,
or of fitting.
And so again, that's another
reason to rationalize alpha.
So I would say, if
you plot your data
and you have to
estimate an alpha,
then I would just say,
well, here's what you do.
And it's as good an
estimate of alpha as any.
And it's very nicely defined.
So we call that-- when
we talk about estimating
the slope here, this is the
formula we're going to use.
So far, this code
has just constructed
a degree distribution,
i.e., the degree, and then
the number of vertices
with that degree
will be the outputs of this
perfect power law function.
We still have to assign
that degree distribution
to an actual set of edges.
OK?
And here's the code
that will do that for.
It will say, given a
degree distribution,
it will create a set of
vertices that do that.
Now, the actual pairing
of the vertices into edges
is arbitrary.
And in fact, these are all
different adjacency matrices
for the same degree
distribution.
That is, every
single one of these
has the same degree
distribution in both the rows
and the columns.
So the actual which vertices
are connected to which
is a second order statistic.
So the degree distribution in
this first order [INAUDIBLE],
but how you want to
connect those vertices up
is somewhat arbitrary.
And so that's a freedom
that you have here.
So for example, if I just
take the vertices out of here
and I just say, all right, every
single vertex in your list,
I'm just going to pair
it up with yourself,
I will get an adjacency
matrix that's all diagonals.
Essentially, all self-loops.
If I take that list
and just randomly
reorder the vertex
labels themselves,
then I get something
that looks like this.
If I just randomly
reorder the edge pairs,
I get something like this.
And if I randomly
relabel both the vertices
and reconnect the vertices
into different edges,
I get something like this.
And for the most part, when
we talk about our randomly
generating our
perfect power laws,
we're going to talk about this.
Which is probably most like
what we really encounter.
It's essentially
something that's
equivalent to randomly
labeling your vertices,
and then randomly
taking those vertices
and randomly pairing
them together.
So that basically
talks about how
we can actually construct a
graph from our perfect power
law edge.
Now, so this is a forward model.
Given a set of these
three sort of parameters,
we can generate a
perfect power law.
But if we're dealing
with data, we often
want slightly
different parameters.
So as I said, before our
three parameters were alpha,
which is greater
than 0, dmax, which
is the highest degree in
the data, which we're saying
is greater than 1, and then
this parameter Nd, which roughly
corresponds to number of bins.
So we can generate a power law
model for any of these values
here that satisfy
these constraints.
So that's a large number.
However, what
we'll typically see
is that we want to
use these parameters.
So we'll want to have an
alpha, a number of vertices,
and a number of edges, is
more often the parameters we
want to work with.
And we can compute those by
inverting these formulas.
That is, if we
compute the degree,
we can sum it to compute
the number of vertices.
And likewise, we can sum the
distribution times the degree
to get the number of edges.
So given these, an alpha and
our model, we can invert these.
All right?
And what you see here is
for a given value of alpha,
the allowed values
of N and M, given--
that is, the values of N and
M that will be a power law.
So what you see is that not
all combinations of vertices,
vertex count and edge count, can
be constructed in a power law.
There's a band here.
This is a logarithmic graph.
It's a wide band.
But there's a band
here of allowable data
that will produce that.
And typically, what
you see is kind
of the middle of this band
is like a ratio of around 10,
which happens to be the
magic number that we see
in lots of our data
sets when people say,
I have power law data.
Someone will ask you, well,
what's your to vertex to ratio?
And [INAUDIBLE] we say,
it's like 8, or 10, or 20,
or something like that.
And again, you see it's
because in order for it
to be power law data, at
least according to this model,
it has to fall into
this band here.
You'll also see this is a
very nonlinear function here.
And we'll get into
fitting that later.
And it's a nasty, nasty
function to invert,
because we have
integer data, and data
that's almost continuous.
And it's a nasty, nasty
bus-- we can do it,
but it's kind of
a nasty business.
But given an alpha and
an N that are consistent,
we can actually then generate
a dmax and an Nd that
will best fit those parameters.
So let's do an example here.
So I didn't just dress up in
this crazy outfit for nothing.
We have a whole Halloween
theme to our lecture today.
So this is-- when I
go trick or treating
with my daughter, of
course, our favorite thing
is to do the distribution of
the candy when we're done.
And so this shows last
year's candy distribution.
We'll see how it varies.
As you can see,
Hershey's chocolate
bars, not surprisingly,
extremely popular.
What else is popular here?
Swedish fish, not so popular.
Nestle's Crunch
bars, not so popular.
Again, I actually found
this somewhat-- this list
hasn't change since when
I went trick or treating.
This is a tough
list to break into.
Getting a new candy that makes
it to Halloween-worthy candy
is pretty hard.
So this year shows the
distribution of all the candy
that we collected.
And here are some
basic information.
So we had 77 pieces of
candy, or distinct edges.
We had 19 types of candy.
Our edge to vertex ratio was 4.
The dmax was 15.
So we had 15 Hershey's Kisses.
N1, we had eight types of
candy that we only got one of.
And then our power
slope was alpha.
And then our fit
parameters to this,
when we actually fit, where
we got 77, 21, and M/N of 3.7.
And this shows you the data.
So this is the candy degree.
And this is the number.
And this shows you
what we measured.
This is the poor
man's slope here.
This is the model.
And then one thing we
can do is actually--
which is very
helpful-- is we can
re-bin the measured data
using the bins extracted
from the model.
And that gets you these red
x's here, or plus signs here.
And we'll discover
that's very important.
Because the data
you have is often
very rarely binned
in a way that's
proper for seeing the
proper distribution.
And we can actually
use this model
to come up with what
a better set of bins
would be, and then bin the
data with respect to that.
So that's just an example
of this in actual practice.
So now that we have a mechanism
for generating perfect power
law, let's see what
happens when we sample it.
Let's see what
happens when we do
the things to it
that we typically
do to clean up our data.
I bring this up because in
standard graph theory, as I've
talked about in
previous lectures,
we often have what
we call random,
undirected Erdos-Renyi
graphs, which
are basically vertices
without direction.
And usually the
edges are unweighted.
So we just have a 0 or a 1.
So very simplified graphs.
I'm actually going to--
getting a little hot here
in the top hat.
So a lot of our graph theory is
based on these types of graphs.
And as we've talked about
before that our data tends
to not look like that.
So one of the things
we do so that we
can apply the theory to
that data is that we often
make with data look like that.
So we'll often make
with data undirected.
We'll often make the
data basically unweighted
and other types of things so
we can apply all the theory
that we've developed over
the last several decades
on these particular types
of very well studied graphs.
So now that we have a
perfect power law graph,
we can see what happens if we
apply those same corrections
to the data.
And so here's what we see.
So we generated a
perfect power law graph.
The alpha is 1.3.
The dmax was 1,000.
Our Nd was 50.
This generated a data set with
18,000 vertices and 84,000
edges.
And so here's a very
simple way to make it.
We're going to make it
undirected by basically taking
the matrix and
adding its transpose,
and then taking
the upper diagonal.
This is actually the best way
to make an adjacency matrix
undirected, to take
that upper portion,
because a lot of the
statistics that-- basically it
saves you having to deal with
a lot of annoying factors of 2.
So a lot of times, we'll
just do A plus A transpose,
but then you get these annoying
factors of 2 lying around.
And so this is a way
to sort of not do that.
So we're getting rid of--
we've made it undirected.
We're made it undirected
by doing that.
We're going to make it
unweighted by basically
converting everything to a 0
or 1, and then back to double.
So that makes it unweighted.
And then we're getting
rid of the diagonal,
so that eliminates self-loops.
So we've done all these things.
We've cleaned up our
data in this way.
So what happens?
Well, so the triangles
were the input model.
Well, now we've
cleaned up our data,
and we see this sort of mess
that we've done to our data.
And in fact, I'll call this--
in keeping with our Halloween
theme here, we'll call this
our witch's broom distribution
here.
And if anybody's looked at
degree redistributions on data,
it will be like you'll
recognize this shape instantly
because you have this
bendiness coming up here.
And then sort of
fanning out down here.
Very common thing that we see
in the data sets that we plot.
And in fact, there's not
an insignificant amount
of literature devoted to trying
to understand these bumps
and wiggles, and do they
really mean something
underlying about the physical
phenomenon that's taking place.
And while it's the case that
those bumps and wiggles may
actually be representative
of some physical phenomenon,
based on this, we
also have to concede
the fact it's also consistent
with our cleaning up procedure.
That is, the thing we're trying
to do to make our data better
is introducing
nonlinear phenomenon
on the data, which we may
confuse with real phenomena.
So this is very much
a cautionary tale.
And so based on
that, I certainly
encourage people not to clean
up their data in that way,
and keep the directedness.
Don't throw away the self-loops.
Keep the weightedness.
Do your degree
distributions in this way.
And live with the fact that
that's what your data really
is like and try and
understand it that way,
rather than trying
cleaning up in this way.
Sometimes you have no choice.
The algorithms that
you have will only
work on data being that's
been cleaned up in this way.
But you have to
recognize you are
introducing a new phenomena.
It's a highly non-linear
process, this cleaning up,
and you have to be
careful about that.
However, given that
we've done this,
is there a way that we can
recover the original power law?
So we can try that.
So we have here is the data that
we-- the original data that we
cleaned up is now these circles.
OK?
And we're going to
take that data set
and compute an alpha
and an N and M from it
from using pour
inversion formulas.
And then compute what the
power law of that would be.
So that's the triangles.
So here's our poor
man's alpha fit.
This is our model.
This is what the model is.
These triangles here is
the model, we're saying.
And then we can say, aha,
let's use the bins that
came from this model
to re-bin these circles
onto these red plus signs here.
So that's our new data set.
And what you see
is that we've done
a pretty good job of recovering
the original power law.
So if we had data that we
observed to look like this,
we wouldn't be sure
it was a power law.
Like, we don't know.
Say, well, what's
this bend here?
And what's this
fanning out here?
But then if you go through
this process and re-bin it,
you can be like, oh, no, that
really looks like a power law.
And so that's a way of
recovering the power
law that we may have lost
through some filtering
procedure.
Here's another example.
So what we're going to do is
essentially take our matrix
and compute the
correlation of it.
We talked a lot
about-- if we say
I have an incidence matrix, we
multiply it to do correlation.
In this case, we're
treating our random matrix
as not an adjacency
matrix, but as
an incidence matrix, a randomly
generated incidence matrix.
And so these are, again,
the parameters that we use.
We're converting it to all
unweighted, all 0's and 1's.
And then we are
correlating it with itself
to construct the
adjacency matrix.
Taking the upper diagonal, and
then removing the diagonal.
And this is the
result of what we see.
So here's our input model.
Again, the triangles.
And then this is the measured--
what we get out from there.
And if you saw this,
you might be like, wow,
that's a really good power law.
In fact, I've certainly seen
data-- I mean, most the time
I would see, yep, that is
a power law distribution.
We absolutely have a
power law distribution.
However, we then
apply our procedure.
So again, we have
our measured data.
OK, we're going to do
our parameters here.
Get our poor man's
alpha parameter.
And then fit, the
triangles are the new fit.
OK.
And then we use
those bins to re-bin.
And we see here that when
we actually re-bin the data,
we get something that looks
very much not like a power law
distribution.
So there's an example
of the reverse.
Before we had data that
didn't look like a power law,
but when we re-binned it,
we recovered the power law.
Here we have data
that may-- just
sort of in this random binning
may look like a power law.
We actually see
it has this bump.
And then continuing with
our Halloween theme,
we can call this the
witch's nose distribution,
because it comes along
here as this giant bump
and then goes back
to a power law.
And this actually,
there's meaning for this.
And we will see this
later in the actual data.
But this is not just that
when you do these correlation
matrices, certain types of them,
particularly self-correlations,
very likely will produce
this type of distribution.
But again, even though
we have this bump,
you would still argue that
our linear power law is still
a very good first order fit.
So we still captured
most of the dynamic range
of the distribution.
And this is now a
delta from that.
And so we're very
comfortable with that, right?
We start with our linear models.
That models most of the data.
And then we have a second order.
If we wanted to, we
could go in and come up
with some kind of second order.
Subtract the linear
model from here
and you would see some kind
of hump distribution here.
And you could then model
your data as a linear model,
plus some kind of correction.
Again, very classic
signal processing way
to deal with our data,
and certainly seems
as relevant here
as anywhere else.
Let's see here.
And again, so the power
law can be preserved
as we talked about there.
So moving on, another
phenomenon that's
often documented
in the literature
is called the densification.
In fact, there's many
papers written on what
is called densification.
This is the observation that
if you construct a graph,
and you compute the
ratio of the edges
to vertices over time,
that ratio will go up.
And there's a lot
of research talking
about the physical
phenomenon that might
produce that type of effect.
And so while that physical
phenomenon might be there,
it's also a byproduct of
just sampling the data.
So for instance here,
what we're going to do
is we created our
perfect power law graph
and we're going to sample it.
We're basically going to
take subsamples of that data.
And we're going to do it
in little chunks, about 10%
of the data at a time.
And the triangles
and the circles
show when we look at each
set of data independently.
And then we have
these lines that
show what happens when
we do it cumulatively.
We basically take 10% of the
data, then 20% of the data,
then 30% and move on here.
And we have two different ways
of sampling our data here.
Random is, I'm just
taking that whole matrix
and I'm randomly
picking edges out of it.
And what you see
is that each sample
has a relatively low edge
to vertex distribution.
But as you add more and more
and more up, it gets denser.
And this is just simply
the fact that given
a finite number of
vertices, you eventually,
if you kept on adding
edges and edges and edges,
eventually it would go--
this would become infinite.
If you add an infinite
number of edges
to a finite
[INAUDIBLE] vertices,
then it will get denser and
denser and denser and denser.
And this is sort of a byproduct
of treating these as 0 and 1's.
And not recognizing.
So this just naturally
occurs through sampling.
The linear sampling here
is where, basically, I'm
taking whole rows at a time.
Or I could have taken
whole columns at a time.
So I'm taking each row and
eventually, all right, I'm
dropping them down.
And there you say it's constant.
So I'm basically for
each-- I'm essentially
taking a whole vertex
and adding it at a time.
And here the sampling is
somewhat independent of it.
The densification-- if
you sample whole rows,
the density of that will be
the same as if you did it.
So this is just good to know.
And good to know about
sampling and these phenomena
can take place, and
then how sampling
can play an important role
in the data that we observe.
Another phenomenon that's
been studied extensively
is what happens to the slope
of the degree distribution
as you add data.
And again, we do this exact
same type of sampling.
And you see here that when we
just-- this data had a slope,
I believe, of 1.3.
And you can see if we
sample it randomly, just
take random vertices, that
the slope starts out very,
very high.
And each sample stays high.
But when we start
accumulating them,
they start converging on
the true value-- converging
from above.
And likewise, when you
do linear sampling,
you have a direction
in the opposite way.
And they both end up converging
onto the true value here
of 1.3.
And so again, this just shows
that the slope of your degree
distribution is also very much
a function of the sampling.
It could also be a function
of the underlying phenomenon.
But again, a cautionary
tale that one
needs to be very aware
of how one's sampling.
And again, these perfect
power law data sets
are a very useful
tool for doing that.
So if you have a real
data set and you're
sampling in some
way, and you want
to know what is maybe real
phenomenon versus what
is sampling effects, if you go
and generate a perfect power
law that's an approximation
of this data set,
you can then very quickly
see which phenomena are just
a result of sampling
a perfect power law,
and which phenomena are maybe
indicative of some deeper
underlying correlations
between the data.
So again, a very
useful tool here.
Moving on, we're going to
talk about subsampling.
And one of the problems that we
have is very large data sets.
And often we can't compute
the degree distribution
on the entire data set.
Or we can't-- and this has
sort of been a bread and butter
of signal processing for years,
where if we want to compute
a background model, that we
don't just simply sum up all
the data.
That we randomly select
data from the data
set, and we use that as a
model of our background.
And that's a much
more efficient way,
from a computational and
data handling perspective,
than simply computing
the mean or the variance
based on the entire data set.
So again, we need good
background estimation in order
to do our anomaly detection.
And again, it's prohibitive
to traverse the data.
So the question is,
can we add accurately
estimate the background
from a sample?
So let's see what happens.
We have a perfect power law.
We can look at what happens
when we sample that.
So we've generated a power law.
OK.
And this is not-- I've changed--
this may look like the degree
distribution, but it's
actually a different plot.
So this is showing every
single vertex in the data set.
All right.
And this shows the N
degree of that vertex.
And we've sorted them.
So the highest degree
vertex is over here
and the lowest degree
vertex is over here.
OK.
So this is all the vertices.
And so this is the true data.
And this is what happens
when we take a 1/40 sample.
I just say, I'm only going
to take 1/40 of the edges.
What does it look like?
Some relatively simple math
here, which I won't go over.
But it's there for you.
We can actually
come up a correction
that allows us to
sample that data based
on the median distributions.
I apologize for the slides.
We will correct them for the
web when we go out there.
All right.
So moving on.
So one of the things
we talk about sampling,
and we talk mainly about
single distributions.
We can also talk about
joint distributions.
So we can actually
use the degree
as a way of labeling the
vertices and look at them.
So it's a way of
compressing-- if we just say,
we're going to label each
vertex by its degree,
this is a way of compressing
many vertices into a smaller
dimensional space
way to look at that.
And we can then count
the correlations.
We can look at the distribution
of how many edges are there
from vertices of this degree
to vertices of that degree?
And so it's a tool for
projecting our data
and understanding
what's going on.
And we can also then
re-bin that data
with a power law, which will
make it more easily understood.
So if we look here, we see that
we had the degree distribution.
So this shows us for a
perfect power law data,
for vertices with this degree
in and this degree out, how many
edges there were between them.
And as you see here,
obviously, there
was a lot of vertices here
between low degree edges,
and not so much here.
But this is somewhat
a misnomer because
of the way the data comes out.
We're not really
binning it properly.
However, if we go and fit a
perfect power law to this data,
and then pick a new
set of bins based
on those, so re-bin the
data, we can see here
that we get a much smoother
uniform distribution.
So while here we
may have thought
that this was an artificially
low dense-- not dense region,
this was artificially
high-- what
you see here is
when you re-bin this
that there's a very smooth
distribution from what
we expect for our
perfect power law here.
That this is a fairly
uniform distribution
with respect to that.
And so basically, it
essentially puts more bins
where we actually
have data as opposed
to wasting bins over here where
we don't really have any data.
Using our perfect
power law model,
we can actually
compute analytically
what this should be.
So here's an example of
what that looks like.
And again, very
similar to what we see.
And given the data, and
a model for the data,
we can then compute the ratio
of the observed to the model
to get a sense of
what data is unusual
versus what we expect from a
perfect power-- or linear fit.
And we see that
very clearly here.
So this is the data just
dividing the data by the model
here.
And you see again,
you see all this data
appears like this is the
ratio, the log of the ratio.
And so it's a-- zero means
that it's essentially
the ratio is 1, so all
of this is expected.
And then we see all
these fluctuations here.
Things that are higher
than we expected
and things that are
lower than we expected.
And so this is the classic-- the
time where you see this most is
whenever they show you a map
of the United States by county
of some-- maybe like it's--
a classic is like a cancer
cluster, or heart
disease, or any phenomena.
And what you see is that certain
counties in the western part
of the United States
are extremely healthy,
and certain counties
are just deadly.
And it's just a
fact that they're
very sparsely populated.
And so they are dealing with
small numbers effect here.
So basically, this is just
showing you oscillations
between 0 and 1 here.
So what we call
Poisson sampling.
And so it makes
it very difficult
to know what those are.
However, if we re-bin the data
and then divide by the model,
we see that the vast majority
of our data, as expected,
is in this normal regime.
Another thing we
can actually do is
we can look at like the
most unexpected data set.
So we can look at the
most typical data set.
Oh, these got moved
here, didn't they.
I don't know what's going
on with PowerPoint today.
But this shows us the
surpluses, the deficits,
and the most typical.
So here's like the most extreme
bin, the most underrepresented
bin, and sort of the
most average bin.
And these are the areas
that they correspond to
in the real data set.
So you can use this
to find extremes
based on a statistical test.
And again, you see
that here again.
We have these
different-- that shows
what the measured over
expected is versus measured.
And you can see, this
is the original data set
and this is the re-bin data set.
And you see that the
re-binning removes
a lot of these very
sparse points over here
and gives you very narrow
distribution around what you
expected.
You can actually go and find
selected edges if you want.
So this just shows the
different types of edges.
The maximum.
If you actually wanted to
go and look at those edges,
these would be maximum,
these would be the minimum,
and these are the other types.
So it's a useful thing.
You can, again,
go, say all right,
we found that if we have an
artificially high correlation
between vertices with this
degree and this degree,
we can then backtrack
and find out
which specific vertices
there are, and see if that's
anything that's interesting.
We can also use this plot to
look at these questions of edge
order.
And so, hopefully,
this will work today.
So here's is a-- if I
randomly select vertices
and I compute their degree
versus-- so basically, what
we did before.
We subsample and then compute
over what is expected.
And we play this.
And you can just see here we get
this sort of-- when we randomly
select the vertices,
we basically
get kind of a
typical-- each sample
looks very much the same.
Again, up there in
these high degrees,
we have this Poisson
sampling effect
where we have some--
this is we have
no vertices, so we get a 0,
which is lower than expected.
And if we have
like two vertices,
we get higher than expected.
And so again, we still
have that Poisson effect.
Interestingly, if we do
linear sampling, which
we take whole rows
at the time, we
get a very different
type of phenomenon.
So you see you get
these-- whenever
you do run into a high
degree row, by definition,
it is unusual.
Which again, means you
have to be very careful.
You're going to run into
this high degree row
eventually by sampling,
but you have to be careful.
It's like, oh, my goodness.
This is a very, very
unusual type of thing.
So again, cautionary
tale about sampling.
All right.
So we've talked a lot
about the theory here.
Let's get into some real data.
So this is our
Reuter's data again.
I showed it to
you the other day.
The various document
distributions we had.
In this case, 800,000 documents,
47,000 extracted entities,
for a total of 6,000,000,
essentially, edges.
So it's a bipartite graph
[INAUDIBLE] between documents.
And four different types.
And we can now look at
the different degree
distributions of the different
classes and see what we have.
So the first one we want to
look at are the locations.
And so we look at the
distribution of the documents
and the entities.
So basically, imagine we took--
so we're very clear here.
So what I'm doing is just
taking this part of the matrix,
and the distribution of the
documents is summing this way.
And the distribution locations
is summing up and down
along the columns.
So for each one
of these types, we
can do those different types.
We have, essentially, two
different degree distributions.
One associated with
the documents and one
associated with the entities.
So this shows us our
document distribution.
So we have the measured data.
We have our fit.
We have our model, and
then our re-binning.
And you know, you could say that
this is approximately a power
law, and that when
you re-bin it,
that this sort of
S-shaped effect
is still there, which probably
means it's really there.
There's something going
on in the data that really
is making this bowing effect.
And so that's really there.
Likewise here, we
have our model.
We have the measured data.
We have our model, alpha,
which is the blue line.
We have the model fit.
And then our re-binning.
And again, you could
say the power law
model's a pretty good
fit, but again, we
have something going on here.
Some kind of phenomenon
going on there.
And we can then do
this for each type.
We can look at
the organizations.
And again, we don't have
as many organizations.
Again, similar types
of phenomenon here.
This is so sparse, it's
difficult to really say
what's going on here.
Of course, we do people,
which is, of course,
people always are
the first thing
that you talk about when
you talk about power law
distributions.
And again, very nicely, we have
our measured data and our fit.
And again, we see this sort
of bent broom distribution
here, bending, and then with
this fan out effect here.
But then when we model
it and re-bin it,
we get something that looks
much more like a true power law.
And you can see that
very nicely here
with the actual person data.
A very good power law.
So this tells us that regardless
of what this underlying data
looks like, this probably really
is a power law distribution.
And then we have the times.
And again, a similar
type of thing here.
Different types of things.
And we actually have
a little spike here.
The Reuter's data has
a certain collection
of times associated with
the actual filing of events.
There's only 35 of them, so
we do get a little spike here,
which is actually
what we expect.
Although you wouldn't
see that really clearly
in the true data, but
when you re-bin it,
this bump comes
out fairly clearly.
So again, proper binning
extremely important.
We can look at our
correlations as well.
So let's just look at the
person-person correlations.
And again, what we saw
here is sort of-- we
see this is the raw data.
So something that looks
very much like a power law.
But when we go through
our re-binning process,
we see kind of this witch's nose
effect here really in the data.
So this would tell you to
first order it's a power law,
but you actually have this
correlation taking place here,
right here.
So that's something that really
seems to be taking place.
You see the same
thing when we do time.
We can look at document.
Let's now look at sampling.
So again, this is the
same sampling that we did.
We're going to
now basically look
at the document densification.
So this is selecting whole rows.
We select a whole document,
so we're getting a whole row.
And this just shows you the
four different types here.
And you see that they
behave exactly as expected.
Each individual
sample is reflective
of the overall
densification, because you're
taking whole rows.
OK?
Now let's take entities.
So now we're cutting
across these.
And now you see
something that looks
much more like random sampling.
When you randomly
select an entity,
that's sort of a random
set of documents.
And again, the
individual samples,
but when you start
summing them up,
you see that they get denser
and denser and denser.
So individual
document has a sort
of a good sample of the
overall distribution.
When you pick a person,
as you take a higher
fraction of the
data, you're going
to get more and more
and more with that.
So again, all consistent
with what we saw before.
A little noisier to
see here, but trust me,
the power law exponent also
behaves exactly as we expected.
Likewise, this is essentially
a linear sampling,
and here's the random
sampling behaving exactly
as we expected.
We can look at the
joint distributions.
So here's the actual-- this is
the location cross-correlation.
So they're showing you basically
the document versus entity
degree distributions.
So this is the measured.
And it's been re-binned.
This is measured
divided by the expected,
so the expected re-bins.
This is measured
divided by the model.
And here's the model, and
expected divided by the model.
And you can basically compare
all these different types
to create different
statistical tests.
And actually, we can find here
the measured re-binned divided
by the expected re-binned.
We can get our surpluses
and deficits and other types
of things in the actual data.
And so here you
see something that
maybe looks like an
artificially high grouping here,
some artificially low,
and some expected.
And you can then
use these as ways
to actually go and find
anomalous documents.
Or documents are
like-- you say, look,
this is the most
typical type of thing.
I mean, people are like, well,
why would you try and find
the most normal?
Well, a lot of times,
you want to be able to,
in terms of summarization,
be like here's
a very representative
set of documents.
They have the
statistical properties.
This is very consistent
with everything else.
Because people will [INAUDIBLE]
like what that mean to be that?
So again, a very useful
way to look at the data.
Do the same thing
with organization.
Again, basically get
the measured re-binned,
the measured divided
by the expected,
the expected re-binned,
the model, refit the model,
and the various different
ratios of all of them, which
you can do to find
various outliers and such.
Again, a very useful.
Interesting that it picked
the most representative one
way up here.
So that's an interesting--
so here's a very unusual
representative sample.
Persons, you can
do the same thing.
And I guess one of the
things I'm also trying to do
is that you see that these
all don't look the same.
Right?
Hopefully, from looking at
these, it's like this one,
the location
distribution is clearly
a little similar to the
organization distribution,
but the person distribution
looks very different.
And the time distribution
So you see that you have to be
careful about-- sometimes we'll
just take all these
different categories
and lump them together
in one big distribution.
And here's a situation,
like these are really
pretty different things.
And you really
want to treat them
as four distinct classes
of types of things.
So as an example
of selected edges,
this just shows
the most typical.
This just shows the various
entities that were selected,
and very representative
document.
And this is a very low
degree, various entities.
So this might show
you entities-- here's
the kind of surplus example.
And we could go in and
actually finding those edges.
Same with the person.
Very generic people,
higher degree.
Here's a very low.
So this person, Jeremy Smith,
is very unusual in terms
of what they connected with.
Surplus ones here.
Can't really read that
over there, but just
to give you examples of
things that you can actually
use this to go in and
actually find things.
All right.
So that brings again
to the lecture part.
So just, again, developing
this background model's
very important for the graphs.
Based on the perfect
power law, gives us
a very simple heuristic for
creating a linear model.
We can then really quantify
the effects of sampling,
which is very important.
Again, traditional
sampling approaches
can easily create
nonlinear phenomenon
that we have to be careful
of and be aware of.
It allows us to
develop techniques
for comparing real data
with power law fits
that we can then use
as statistical tests
for finding unusual
bits of data.
It's a very classic
detection theory here.
Come up with a model
for the background.
Create a linear fit
for that background.
Then use that model
to then quantify
the data to see which
things are unusual.
Again, just using
very classic detection
theory, the techniques.
Again, having a
background model being
the linchpin of doing that.
And I'm not saying that this--
this is very recent work.
This parallel model-- something
we did in the last year or so.
We just published
it this summer.
I can't guarantee that in
three or four years from now
that people will still
be using this model,
because it is very new.
But I think this
is representative
of the kinds of things that
will be in three or four
or five years, that
people-- it may not be this,
but something like this
to characterize our data.
And so I think it's
very useful there.
All right.
So with that, we will
take a short break
and then we will
show the example code
and talk about the assignment.
So very good.
Thank you very much.